e
herkese Merhaba Hoş geldiniz Öncelikle
su Şu anda ben aslında bir hayalim daha
gerçek gerçekleştirdim Bu zamana kadar
hep YouTube kanallarında en çok
izlediğim kanal olabilir tediks Ve
hayalini kurmuştum Ben de bir gün orada
konuşabilecek miyim ben de bugün kendimi
orada ifade edebilecek miyim ve şu anda
burada olduğuma Gerçekten inanamıyorum
bana bu fırsatı verdiğiniz için Tekrar
çok teşekkür ederim Altınbaş
Üniversitesi ni Ben burada hiç kimsenin
hayatından örnekler vermeyeceğim sadece
kendi hayatımdan Size birkaç şey
anlatmak istiyorum Umarım Onun içinden
Siz de kendinize yorumlayarak ona göre
adımlar atarsanız
bu benim doğduğum ez
Ben 10 Lite
1999 94 yılında bu evde doğdum
şurası alt kısmı küçükbaş hayvanların
kaldığı yerde iki kat tad Avis
kalıyorduk şu dışta gördüğünüz küçük
yerde Orası bizim mutfağımız the
tanrılarımız ekmeğimiz orada pişerdi
şurada bir tane daha var orta büyükbaş
hayvan larımız kalıyor kalıyordu Bu
gördüğünüz etraf İşte bizim bahçemizdir
Ben 10 yaşına kadar orada büyüdüm bu
ama bugünün en küçük halin bundan daha
küçük bir halim yok yani çünkü
bilmiyorum fotoğraf makinesi yok
herhalde çekmemiş lera işte babam
kesiyordu Saçlarımızı Biraz isim başım
dağınık 4 yaşındayım burada
Ben
10 yaşındayken İstanbul'a geldik biz Çok
ani bir gelişimiz oldu
annemizi kaybettik
dokuz kardeşliği bir kalabalık
yaylarinin bir
çocuğuyum ay annemizin Hani ani
vefatından sonra İstanbul'a geldik apar
topar
Ondan sonra İstanbul hayatımız başladı
bıç ok Burası benim hayatımın en önemli
dönüm noktası Burası yatılı okudum
okulun bahçesi
burada artık İstanbul'a geldiğimizde çok
büyük bir şehir küçücük bir şehir köyden
koskocaman bir dünyaya açılıyor sunuz ve
orada teksiniz birkaç evden oluşuyor
köyünüz ve Sizde farklı olarak dünyaya
gelmişsiniz etrafınızda size benzer hiç
kimse yok Herkesin
bu olması gereken gibi uzunları ama
sizinki öyle değil bu kocaman şehre
geldiğinde gerçekten kendimi çok değişik
hissetmiştim acaba demiştim Ben de mi
bir yanlışlık var yoksa insanların
insanların insanlarda mı bir sorun var
hep bunu kendime sormuştum bu
yatakhanede ya yatakhaneye ilk gittiğim
gün Okulun ismi nedense
Eğitimhane geçiyordu ve biz de işte
yetimhanenin anlamı ne annesi ya da
babası olmayan insanların kaldığı yer
Halbuki öyle değilmiş küçük yaşta olduğu
için o bilince var mıyorsun ama o
yatakhaneye gittiğim ilk günü
herhalde hayatım boyunca hiç
unutmayacağım altı yılım benim bu
bahçede geçti ve beni ben yapan her yer
Aslında bu yatakhane oldu çünkü burada
Çocuklar biraz acımasız
nasıl
aslında burada sorun ailelerde Çünkü
insanların da farklı insanların da
Hayatta olması gerektiğini onları nasıl
davranmamız gerektiğini aileler
çocuklarını öğretmiyor burada çok acı
nasıl şeyler de durdum duydum
[Müzik]
sadece işte O zamanlar daha protezin yok
ameliyat olmamışım
koşamıyorum doğru düzgün Yürüyemiyorum
ve arkadaşlarım beni oyuna almıyorlardı
ya da bir şey yapmak istediklerinde işte
Akalin senin elin yok Sen tutamazsın
falan gibi söyleyenleri oluyordu ben hiç
al şey yapamıyordum hep kenara
çekiliyorum ama bunu yaş aldıkça Tabii
ki de anlıyorsun öğreniyorsun bazı
şeyler ve bu fotoğraftan Birkaç ay sonra
ben artık ameliyat olmuştum ve protez
takmaya başlamıştım Bu gördüğünüz gibi
hava sıcak ama benim aramda bot var
Çünkü o zamanlar benim ayağımın bilek
kısmı sadece yoktur bacağım uzundu
normal ayakkabı giyemediğim için hep yaz
kış bot yemek zorunda kalıyordum Hatta
Babam da gider de bana Yeşilyurt alırdı
Köydeyken niye yeşil bak alırdı onu da
bilmiyorum
24kasım 2006 yılında Ben ameliyat oldum
ve 3 ay sonra protez takmaya başladım
İşte insan hayatında iki kere doğruymuş
Ben de ikinci kez o protezi taktığım gün
oldu çünkü bizden Boyunuz yükseliyor
benim sol bacağım 13 santim Kısaydı sağ
bacağıma göre hep yan yürümek zorunda
kalıyordum buradaki tasarım kısalmıştır
buradaki tasarım uzadığı için inanılmaz
şiddetli derecede Bel ağrılarım oluyordu
ve bizden boyun uzuyor ilk defa
hayatınızda 12 yaşındaydım o zaman
Bu normal ayakkabı giymeye başlıyorsunuz
kıyafetiniz değişiyor şekliniz değişiyor
insanlara sizin size karşı olan
bakışları değişiyor veren
2006 yılında Aslında tekrar doğdum
protez taktıktan sonra
ara yani İyi bir öğrenci olduğunu
düşünüyorum az çok iyi bir eğitim
hayatını geçti Çünkü hep mücadele etmek
zorundaymışım gibi hissediyorum kendimi
başarmak zorundaymışım gibi hissediyorum
kendimi
böyleyiz Gerçekten sen Emek vermeden
ekmek yemiyorsun Ben de hayatımın her
aşamasında bu şekilde ilerlemek
istiyorum Evet Ee spor hayatı malise
yılında başladım bir okul projem
sayesinde şu anda bu mesleği yapıyorum
ve karşınızdayım bilgisayar lisedeki bir
projem sayesinde
yüzme ile tanıştım ve Aslında yüzmek
için çok geç bir açtı benim için Çünkü
ben kendimden hep dört yaşında 4yaş
Küçüklerle okudum köyde Bizim Okul
olmadığı için maalesef
İstanbul'a geldiğinizde Biz okula
başladık
bu konudan dolayı Hatta şey bir anım var
İstanbul'a Biz geldik o zaman öyle yarım
yamalak Türkçe biliyorum hiç bilmiyordum
Hatta Sınıfa ilk girdim Çocukların hepsi
benden kısa bana dediler ki abla dediler
yanlış sınıfa girdim dediler ben de şu
kaldım hiçbir şey diyemedim çocuğa
ya ondan sonra
spor hayatına başladıktan sonra çok geç
başladı 19 yaşındayım ben yüzmeye
başladığında 19 yaş yüzmek için çok
büyük bir yaş Sonuçta spora 45 yaşında
başlamanız gerekiyor Eğer ilerde
başarılı bir sporcu olmak istiyorsanız
Ama bu Paralimpik için biraz farklı
Paralimpik kelimesini ilk defa mı
duyduğunuz ya da biliyor musunuz çok bir
fikrim yok açıkçası Paralimpik Olimpiyat
oyunlarının
engellilerin katıldığı bir Paralimpik
oyunlar diye geçiyor engelli bir
ağaçların katıldığı yarışmalar oluyor
genelde ve orada yaş guruplarına göre
değil Senin engel derecesine göre seni
sınıflandırılırlar sen o şekilde
yarışlara katıla biliyorsun 19 yaşındaki
biri işte 12 yaşındaki biriyle
değişebilir 39 yaşındaki biriyle de
yüzebilirsiniz engel derecesine göre ya
Hoş bulduk Onun içinden diğer
rakiplerine göre çok daha avantajlıdır
Çünkü boyun daha uzunluğu ya da
kas gücüm daha güçlüydü onun için çok
hızlı adapte oldum üç ay içinde yeni
Türkiye Şampiyonasına gönderdiler
inanamadım Tabii ki de orada Türkiye
şampiyonu olmuştum ilk yarışın
Kayseri'de olmuştu Hatta sonra da bizim
altı yemeğe götürmüşlerdi
böyle 40 tane de sığmıyor Ayrıca
söylemek istedim mi
böyle yarışlardan birkaç tane
bu görsel
ama işte asıl anlatmak istediğim nokta
burası Ben şu anda Türkiye'deki ilk
bedensel engelli kazanan söylerim Ve
tabii ki de
bu zamana gelene kadar ben de çok fazla
Tokat yedim çok fazla kaybettim ben şey
çok inanıyorum gerçekten
bir tane bir şey kaybediyorsunuz ve
gerçekten onun yerine yenisi geliyor
sadece can kaybı dışında kaybettiğimiz
canların yerine hiçbir şey gelmiyor ama
Mesleğinizi kaybediyorsunuz başka bir
buluyorsunuz onda daha iyi oluyorsunuz
Ben de insanları bana söyledi Sen
Ayağında protez var Sen bu kadar saat
nasıl ayakta durup antrenman
yaptıracaksın işte ellerim yok
kronometre nasıl tutacaksın Ben İstanbul
Üniversitesi spor bilimleri fakültesi
kazandım dedim bana dediler ki be sen
sakat nasıl spor yapacaksın dediler yok
yani
mı böyle bir zihniyetle uğraştım hep Ama
şu anda istediğimi yaptım
başardım
Tabii ki de hala ayağıma taş değdirmeye
çalışan insanlar var onları da
yenebileceğini düşünüyorum Onların da
üstesinden gelebileceğini düşünüyorum
benim
sen her şeyde böyle biz bir şeyleri
denerken çok çabuk vazgeçiyoruz Ya ben
şimdi Türkiye'deki ilk bedensel engelli
kadın oturuyorum tamam
Sen niye İlkim niye benden önce hiç bu
adımı atmak atmaya ihtiyaç duymayan
insanlar oldu Belki de olmuştur da benim
kadar ses çıkarmadılar ya da onlara daha
çok insan engelli oldu ya da fırsat
vermediler ya da hemen çabuk PES edip
kenara geçtiler Ben onu yapmak istemedim
Niye başka bir meslek yapayım ki ben
zaten en iyi bildiğim iş bu dedim ona
göre adım attım
şimdi de çok güzel öğrenciler
yetiştiriyorum Hatta şu anda yarışmamız
var ama ben buradayım öğrencilerini
bıraktım geldim
böyle istediğiniz her mesleği Özen engel
çıkarsa çıksın yapın kendinize inanın ev
Sen
benim hayatımın
özür dilerim
abone ol
1900'lü
[Alkış]
E bu fotoğrafı baktığınızda ne
görüyorsunuz
bu iki farklı insan ben ve kardeşim
abone ol
Allah ikimize de engelli sayılıyoruz
Çünkü al otizmli
Benim ellerim yok her işimi kendim
yapabiliyorum benim ayağımda protez var
Ben gidiyorum İstediğin her yere
ulaşabiliyorum
edebiliyorum
işimi yapabiliyorum
arkadaşlarınla dışarı çıkabiliyorum Ali
Arı otizmli eli ayağı tutuyor 10 tane
parmağı var iki ayağı var
Bu gözleri çok güzel bakayım
mı Tamam hadi konuşamıyor
Sen kendini ifade edemiyor
bir tek başına ablam olmadan dışarı
çıkamıyor
İyi o zaman biz neye göre insanları
engellemiş Siz gibi bakıyoruz niye
Sadece sosyal medyada insanların
malzemesi oluyoruz bu
ama biz artık bunu yaşamak istemiyoruz
Evet
ben Ali ile dışarıda yürüdüğüm zaman ben
dikkat çekiyorum abi alkış yaptığı için
dikkat çekiyor çocuk hareketli diye niye
dışarı çıkartıyorsunuz evde kalsın diyen
insanlar da oluyor
Ya siz niye dışarıdasın
Ben bu hafta 16 Mayıs engelliler haftası
biliyor muydun
o herkes engelliler gününü kutluyor
Sen niye kutluyorsunuz Ben niye Engelli
olduğum için bugün kutlayayım ya
da tam tersi farkındalık yaratmanız
gerekiyor
bu okullarda bunu eğitimin verilmesi
bu ilkokulda
var bunu bire bir şahit oldum
çocuğum Elif bir kolu bir bacağı
olmadığı için sınıftaki öğrencilerin
psikolojisi bozulmuş bütün velilere
çocuğu sınıftan başka bir sınıfa
götürmeleri için kendi aralarında imza
toplamışlar neden Çocuk engelli diye
ben kendi çocuğun psikolojisini bozuyor
Muş
mı böyle zihniyetler var bu zihniyetleri
yok etmek için ile sosyal medyanın da o
gün kutlamayın sadece birkaç insanı
anlatın beraber yaşamanız gerektiğini ya
Bu bir insanın İlla Elin Kolun olması
şart değil ki
bu şart değil düşünceniz sağlam olsun
düşünceniz yerinde olsun
15 yaşındaki bir çocuk Bazen beni
görüyor korkuyor Niye Korkuyor Çünkü
ailesi onu anlatmamış
var ya da dilbazlar da diyor Aaa elinle
değişik ayağındaki ne
Sen niye anlatıyoruz
abone ol
ben sadece şunu söylemek istiyorum
Gerçekten sen insanlar
İnsanlara insanlarda en çok zorlandığım
şey sürekli
yapabildiğimi bir şeyleri tek başıma
yapabildiğim ispatlamakla geçiyor Bütün
ömrüm Ben 28 yaşındayım ya kendime
tanımaya başladığımdan beri ben bunu
yaşıyorum İnsanın sürekli yardım etmeye
çalışıyor ve bir dur Beni Uzaktan bir
izle bir yapabileceklerimi bir Gülgör
ondan sonra bana yardım et İnsanlar
kendi vicdanları tatmin etmek için bize
yardım ediyorlar ya da başka birine
yardım ediyorlar öyle
Ve o an çünkü sen bana yardım etmeye
çalıştığı zaman başkası görüyor acil ne
kadar iyi bir insan yardım ediyor
ben bunu çok yaşadım
metrobüse biniyorum elime bakıyor
yanındakini döküyor ağrıyor baksana eli
yok diyor
bu elim yok diyeceğine Yer Ver Kalker
ver Yani illa ben bunu Sözde sana
söylemem mi gerekiyor
bu insanlar çok önyargılı
ya ben bu önyargıları yıkmak için bu
yola çıktım
yapabileceklerimi herkese göstermek için
bu yola çıktım Eğer ben bunu başarabildi
isem Sen benden daha çok başarısı Çünkü
senin iki tane sağlamayan var 10 tane
parmağım var Eğer Burası yerinde ise da
hiçbir şeye ihtiyacım yok ki fazla da
lafı uzatmak istemiyorum buradan
neslican.tay ın bir sözüyle bitirmek
istiyorum Biz bir bacaktan ibaret
değiliz biz çok daha fazlası yız Mekanı
cennet olsun
[Alkış]